a bit of known goal the membership
number should have been released frankly
in the contest started and that's why I
think it's the right thing for Peter to
have done to stood down because as he
said his own words it was becoming a
distraction I really wanted to get on to
talking about you know the policies what
it is I'm going to bring forward finally
the next first minister of Scotland but
this is a chance to reform this is a
chance to refresh we'll not just have a
new leader of the SNP but a new chief
executive at the party as well we've
already got enormous talent for example
with Stephen Flynn and Maddie black
recently appointed as leader and Deputy
leader of the party at Westminster two
so a real new chapter for the party
which I think can be extremely positive
indeed